all right more proposals coming next
month when the nfl has a virtual annual
meeting second straight year they won't
be doing it in person because of the
pandemic one of the proposals and this
comes from the buffalo bills something
that i know
coaches with other teams believe in
delaying any hiring until after the
super bowl barring interviews until
after the conference championship games
and and
i've seen judy batista of nfl media a
couple of times now quote an owner who
says that that would be unenforceable
there's a difference between
unenforceable and unwilling to enforce i
think this is a rule that the nfl would
be unwilling to enforce because they
know
that plenty of people would break it
sure and the nfl in my view generally is
averse
to letting the world know we got a bunch
of cheaters in here so
no rule is unenforceable if you're
committed to enforcing it
they're not committed to enforcing it
that's what makes it unenforceable no
you're right and and listen it's a hard
one to enforce i mean it just as we know
it really is
oh hey you know we're we were talking
about this player and you know this
coach that's on your staff with the
owner and now oh now it comes up to
possible hires that could happen down
the down the road i just think it would
be really hard uh i wish but if you
still can't hire the guy until after the
super bowl yeah if you are prohibited
from signing the contract until after
the super bowl yes right you have to
still have you
it that that's right because you know
what the morning after the super bowl
there's a chance yes that cal mcnair
says why are we hiring david culley we
haven't interviewed byron leftwich did
you see what the buccaneers did
yesterday offensively exactly what they
did defensively why well let's bring in
todd bowles so even even if you think
you know what you're going to do you
still have a chance because the contract
hasn't been signed
to say we're going in a different
direction because we're we're smitten by
this candidate based upon what we saw in
the biggest stage in football right
minds can be swayed right to see oh
divisional weekend championship weekend
super bowl like whoa you know i've never
really watched this team and got a
chance to sit down and watch them all
all year in a single game or whatever
and wow it was three or four games in a
row where you're right like i know this
guy was on the radar but maybe we need
to do a little more due diligence and
dive into this guy and do that i do
think i i think there's merit i would
like to see it done i would it is unfair
regardless it is unfair the interviews
themselves
might not be as impressive from some of
those guys too who are coaching a team
like we talked about this year with eric
b enemy you know i think eric b enemy is
he's a football coach he wasn't going to
like sell the chiefs offense and the
team down the river just to go like oh
screw it i'm going to have the most
impressive interview ever i'm not even
going to think about the game this week
or my game plan and do that stuff that's
not in the dna of a lot of these coaches
it's not and it makes it kind of
you know almost unfair to those
organizations that they have to deal
with that anyways so i i'd be all for it
and i think that's something that should
happen
as someone explained it to me this year
during the hiring cycle
when the offensive coordinator who is
getting ready for a playoff game and
just spent the day
getting the game or presumably spent the
day getting the game plan ready when
that person goes home at night to spouse
or significant other
the first question isn't hey how's the
game planning yeah right this weekend
right the first question is have you
heard anything right about are you gonna
get that job that gives us life-changing
money
when's it when's the interview when's
the interview again are you ready for
the interview
tonight you know what if i was you
i'd prepare for the interview yeah yeah
you know what you're doing with your
offensive game plan you got this far
very rare i'll prepare for the interview
instead so if you can't have interviews
then you you avoid that conflict of
interest it is an unavoidable and
irreconcilable conflict of interest for
the assistant coach who on one hand
should be spending every waking moment
getting his his team ready
for the next game and on the other hand
thinking
i i got to put my best for foot forward
in these interviews you know maybe
that's why there's this this
thing that rattles around the nfl that
eric banemy doesn't do well in his
interviews maybe he won't prioritize
himself i don't think he's a team right
i don't think he will i don't i mean
everything i hear or know about the guy
i mean he's a real football coach he's
just not in he's not going to do that
and i think there's a lot of them that
are like that where it's just like
as we talk about there's a lot of you
know
army soldier aspect of football right
and and it's just you know a man's man's
game and i'm here doing this job and man
i've worked hard and i don't want to let
these guys down in the locker room and i
don't want to let my fellow coaches down
and doing all that and i think it's very
hard to put your best foot forward in
that scenario uh when you're wired the
way a lot of these coaches are so i want
this changed i would like it and i think
it's worth it because of what you said
if it can change one or two hirings a
year to me that's worth it and uh i'm
all for it
yeah i i i like it and i i don't like
the fact that
i don't
like you know i i i just don't like the
fact that owners are using reporters who
work for the league
to throw water on this you know i that
that doesn't sit well with me because i
think it's the right thing to do
and i think that that the nfl should be
committed to enforcing its rules and
this idea of oh oh we can't
bull crap you can enforce it if you want
to enforce it and the commissioner tells
all the teams this is how it's going to
be and anybody who steps out of line go
talk to the 2012 new orleans saints
about what the consequences are going to
be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports